- People are hating, but mark my words:
I will still. Get. The job. Done.
- Yeah, so it’s just babysitting the rookies while I take the night off.
- Haha, I love that I have to mentor you.
- Time for bed—
- YOU CAN’T SMOKE.
- So the Raven killed them all. Goodnight. See you in your nightmares.
- YOU GUYS ARE DEAD WHEN FITZPATRICK GETS BACK FROM THE CONCERT.
- Yo I’m….
- ♪♪♪ [Rapid rapping] Looking slick, throwing picks
Asking Vic, will I stick? Am I the franchise guy? ♪♪♪
- [Together:] We don't know!
- CHILDREN ARE NOT THE FUTURE.
- I AM THE FUTURE.
Wait, who are you?
- The babies...have been sat.
- I'm Garrett Gilbert, and I've actually been around since 2014.
- Teamy wants you to subscribe.
But Teamy also wants...a hug.
Just because we be Team Monster
don't mean we be monster monster.
AHHH MUST EAT TO SURVIVE.